when you go down 21-0 lindsay uh and the
flow of the game is totally predicated
on all right let's find a way to get
back in it you got a two-minute drive at
the end of the half and you know they
were able to score and you kind of
really never got back into our normal
down and distance operation we could be
underneath the center have some run back
run past balance and and things like
that so i think that puts a lot of
stress on the quarterback on the
offensive line based on how we felt like
was the best way to move the ball and i
thought he did a lot of good things uh
we're fine yeah we're three and one
we're we're in a good place i think you
know i've
i've certainly been a part of a lot
worse than this and
first voice was sean mcveigh the coach
of the rams and then jared goff the
quarterback of the rams a day after a
55-40 loss to the tampa bay buccaneers
that had some historic numbers for jared
goff it was tied for eighth all-time
single game passing yardage 517 tied for
third all-time single game attempts with
68 and tied for first all-time single
game completions with 45 although he was
criticized for too many mistakes missed
reads bad throws etc chris you took a
closer look at the game yesterday and
you had a change of heart i did i really
did mike i mean i came away after
watching the film going it's one of the
best games i've ever seen
jared goff play i mean other than maybe
that minnesota game last year right was
that a thursday night football game
where he tore up your vikings at home in
la right uh but but that game was
amazing but the thing i would say that
was different about that game is it was
easy all night you know there was good
pass protection people were wide open
right we talked a lot that night like
anthony barr was covering brandon cooks
and todd gurley 40 yards down the field
a few times and that shouldn't be
this was different now like
the jared goff he made a lot of big time
throws in the football game he got beat
to crap in this football game you heard
mcveigh talk about they got behind right
and they had to abandon the run game and
that buccaneers d line right now is the
real deal when you talk about uh via
vita or vitavia i keep messing his damn
name up and damma can sue and the nfl
defense mvp shaquille barrett right now
on the edge they were all over jared
goff and he made a lot of big throws to
bring them back into that game and i
know people are going to sit here and go
well he threw three interceptions and
i'm gonna go only one of them was his
fault he can't block people
and throw the ball at the same time and
that's really what happened i mean they
just was it was a bad day from the rams
offensive line they got a little unlucky
but man mike he played tough and you
know me i'm about like oh it's easy to
throw to 20 yard uh 20 yard in cuts when
guys are wide open he was making 20 yard
out throws 18 yard out throws you know
crosses across the middle into very
tight coverage he missed two throws in
the third quarter where they had to
settle for field goals on two drives
instead of maybe getting a touchdown if
he makes a big throw but okay
you know you're not going to be perfect
it's not a sport of perfection and when
you're getting hit the way he was
getting hit and having to throw down
after down you're gonna miss some throws
so i stand corrected for being a little
critical on of him monday morning that's
really what i want to say almost i
apologize i stand corrected i
self-scouted thyself and jared goff
really should be proud of the way he
played and i think it's something you
can build on if you're the rams and
jared goff i really do
yeah because you're not going to face a
defensive front like that every game
your offensive line's not going to have
a game like that you're not going to be
down 21 nothing every game and i think
maybe it gives them confidence that
whenever they do have to put their their
foot on the gas pedal for the passing
game they can which is encouraging in
the event that they find themselves
without todd gurley at some point this
year that's exactly it mike i mean i i
think you know you always like you know
we talk about franchise quarterbacks
right a franchise quarterback gets you
out of those bad moments when the team's
not playing well and he can go hey get
on my back i'll carry us through this
little period until we until we kind of
get our feet back underneath us and
we're playing good football and i do
give jared goff a lot of credit because
he did that for the los angeles rams on
sunday you know again i mean they were
down what at what point 21-0 and then he
brought them back into where this game
was 28-20 then they lost control of the
game again and they got down 38-20 and
he brought him back again to make it
45-40 and we went oh gosh watch out here
come the rams uh so he does he really
hung tough and made some game-changing
type throws if you're watching on tv the
interception to levante david that was
the only egregious mistake he made all
day but look at that throw that was into
phenomenal tight coverage i mean he
really stuck a lot of football another
one
phenomenal coverage uh that's what
really jumped out to me i mean again
mike look i mean you're just seeing it
right there it's throw after throw the
defenders are right there and he's put
in the perfect spot so it was just it
was encouraging to see that goff can
carry the team when need be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports